there have been some changes to it
and the meeting
of mr lavrov
and the minister of foreign affairs and
international cooperation of rwanda
within his working visit to moscow that
had been previously scheduled for
september the 10th
has been rescheduled for a later date on
the 11th of september sergey lavrov will
meet deputy
chairman of the council of ministers and
minister foreign affairs of the state of
carter who will be in moscow on a short
working visit
the two ministers will cover
topical issues of further promotion of
the whole range of russian qatari
relations there will be an in-depth
exchange of
opinions on afghanistan they will also
compare notes on regional and
international affairs with a special
emphasis on political and
diplomatic settlements of crisis
situations in the middle east and north
africa on the 13th of september sergey
lavrov will meet the state secretary for
foreign affairs international
cooperation and telecommunications of
the republic of san marino who will be
in moscow on a working visit between
the 12th and the 15th of september the
meeting will give an opportunity to
exchange views on the current state and
prospects of russian san marinian
cooperation in bilateral and
multilateral formats as well as a
substantive discussion on international
agenda
on the 15th of september sergey lavrov
will take part in the meeting of
ministries of foreign affairs
of the council of foreign ministers of
csto countries the event will take place
in dushanbe on the eve of the csto
collective security session
cheered by the minister of foreign
affairs of tajikistan
the activities of the organizations
during the international intercessional
period will be summed up
opinions will be exchanged on the
military and political situation in the
csto collective security regions with a
focus on the situation in afghanistan
the documents to be submitted to the
csto collective security council
including the csto collective security
council declaration will be approved in
the format of a joint meeting
participants in the meeting will
consider a substantial package of
decisions relating to foreign policy
military and anti-terrorism cooperation
within the organization
as for any additional events and changes
to the schedule of the minister
we will
inform you promptly and now on to the
international
agenda north stream 2
recently the
last pipe of the second line of north
stream 2
has been finalized
it remains to connect the pipeline
sections one coming from the german
coast and the other from danish
territorial waters and to carry out
commissioning work
as you probably know
the representatives of gazprom can have
confirmed that the first gas supplies to
the european market while the nord
stream 2 could be made by the end of the
year
in other words the construction of one
of the world's largest energy
infrastructure facilities is nearing
completion
it is clear to everyone including the
opponents of nordstrom 2 who fiercely
opposed the construction that it is
impossible to stop it
it is time to stop obstructing this
important project it is time to agree on
reasonable and mutual beneficiary
parameters
of the pipeline's operation the timing
of the start of commercial deliveries
depends on the position of the german
regulator we expect that millions of
european consumers will soon be able to
receive russian gas by the surest most
economical and let me point this out
environmentally friendly route the
carbon footprint of gas transportation
via nordstrom 2 is more than 5 times
lower compared to alternative routes
all materials in this regard have been
presented strategically north stream 2
will strengthen europe's energy security
for decades to come
the gas pipeline was constructed using
state-of-the-art technologies
and complies with all internationally
accepted norms
we have explained for many years when we
answered questions reacted to criticism
and
rebutted fakes that nordstream 2
is a purely economic project and russia
has no plans whatsoever to use it for
any other purposes
we sincerely hope that nordstrom 2 will
cease to be subject of all sorts of
political speculations and predix
for
unlawful restricted restrictive measures
and bogus stories and will no longer be
part of confrontational agenda
given the participation of major
european energy companies in the funding
of the project
and the involvement of hundreds of
european contractors in the construction
process
north stream 2 like its predecessor
north stream 1 is in fact a positive
example of a mutually beneficial
partnership between russia and europe
which we are ready to build on the
principles of respect for mutual
interests and mutual benefit
i really want to be heard this time by
european citizens who live in various
towns and cities in europe because
they have been victims of their own
media outlets for so many times these
media outlets distorted the data
they have
supported the ideas of various companies
supported by relevant lobbying
structures
at this stage we are currently hoping
that europeans
citizens of european countries
will here will understand
and will realize
that
they will benefit from this joint
international project
as for the attempts to link the
beginning of the normal operations of
north stream ii with other topics
firstly we continue to see them as
examples of
inappropriate politicization of energy
cooperation which fundamentally
contradicts market principles
secondly
as russian president vladimir putin
confirmed at his meeting with german
chancellor
angela merkel
we are ready to continue gas transit
through ukraine but this issue is purely
commercial and depends on many factors
including the volume of future european
purchases and the competitiveness of
alternative routes
on to the situation in afghanistan on
the in the evening of the 7th of
september new
appointments to the inter interim
government of afghanistan which includes
representatives of the taliban movement
were announced the head of the newly
established cabinet and its members have
the status of acting members which seems
to indicate that the process of forming
the government and the
power vertical in the country is
incomplete it cannot be ruled out that
it will include other structures which
will make it possible to ensure the
inclusiveness of the new government
we will closely follow these
developments russia consistently
advocates taking due account of the
interests of all ethnopolitical forces
in afghanistan while building the new
state we believe that this is the only
way to achieve sustainable peace and
harmony in afghan society and ensure the
peaceful reconstruction of the country
and now a few words about the
humanitarian aspects of the situation in
this country afghanistan has
traditionally been among the recipients
of russian humanitarian aid including
through the united nations
since 2018
we have provided
9 million us dollars in essential food
aid through the
world food program it has been
distributed by u.n humanitarian
personnel to the most vulnerable
populations
among other things our country has
played an important role in developing
the logistical capacity of human un
humanitarian agencies in afghanistan by
donating a total of more than 70
vehicles
to the wfp vehicle fleet as an in-kind
contribution we're speaking about 40
camas vehicles in 2011 and 31 camas
vehicles in 2015.
we understand that the current difficult
military and political situation along
with the negative impact of the covet-19
pandemic has led to additional economic
health and food security challenges
for the population
it is worth recalling that russia
ensured that u.n security council
resolution 2593 on afghanistan adopted
on the 13th of august calls on all
donors and international humanitarian
organizations to provide aid to
afghanistan and the major refugee
recipient countries
regrettably
despite our suggestions the us british
and french sponsors of the document
flatly refused to include in the
resolution references to the obligation
to strictly adhere to the guidelines of
the
world humanitarian aid organization
set forth in the unga resolution
46-182 as well as the points about the
detrimental impact of the freezing of
national financial assets on the
economic and humanitarian situation in
afghanistan
russia intends to participate in a
high-level meeting on the humanitarian
situation in afghanistan to be held on
september the 13th in geneva at the
level of permanent representative to the
un office in geneva
we have taken note
of statements that were made by the
ministry of foreign affairs of germany
during the governmental press conference
that
by official
rep spokesperson of the foreign ministry
andreas assam
we have taken note of the new batch of
alleged
activities
of a certain ghostwriter hacker group
allegedly coordinated by our government
against the state parliaments in germany
what can i say about this
the story about allegations that russia
was involved in hacking attacks on
german lawmakers is by no means new
it's quite old in fact the german side
has already promoted similar stories
back in 2015 and 2017.
it is indicative
and yes
the internet remembers it all
you can simply look it up
on your search engine and you will see
that after the 2017 parliamentary
election campaign the then german
interior minister thomas demasier was
forced to admit that there was no
russian influence on the vote
apparently
berlin has no intention to draw lessons
from this situation and despite our
repeated appeals through diplomatic
channels our partners in germany never
provided any evidence of russian
involvement in the hacking attacks
i emphasize we have used the in existing
diplomatic channels
russian proposals to conduct a joint
investigation were ignored at the same
time
germany initiated two packages of
european union anti-russian sanctions on
these spaces
we are convinced that
when we speak about the so-called ghost
rider group
there is also a foreign policy motif
in this case
because there are similar groundless
accusations against us from the united
states
it seems to be just another
pr trick in the context of political
struggle in germany in the run-up to
bundestag elections
they are due to take place on the 26th
of september this year
at the same time regarding the
accusations against russia berlin is
trying to mimic its overseas teacher
like a bad pupil probably in the hope to
get a good grade and to earn some
political points
what can i say such statements that
berlin has made
have nothing in common with the real
fight against threats in the information
environment and strengthening
international cooperation in the field
of information security
and such statements such
uncorroborated accusations
are opposed by russia
with a consistent course towards
establishing equal professional
relations with all states both
bilaterally and on regional and global
platforms
let me remind you
on the 3rd of september we recently held
a constructive and business-like
consultation on international
informational security in a construct
on the margins of the russian german
interdepartmental high-level working
group on security policy issues
and by the way we have agreed to make
them regular the information
about this event is available on our
website therefore we consider the
subsequent remarks as the desire of some
german politicians to show their main
ally this lobby is guided by
that the russians are being kept at bay
and there will be no
in transatlantic security and at the
same time to replicate the
well-worn threat from the east trope on
the eve of the bundestag elections in
germany
i have given you quite a few facts but
let me
give a recommendation to our partners in
berlin
it would be right to get back
to civilized election campaigning
without any insinuations
and groundless accusations against other
countries
and if you accuse someone of something
it would be nice to give at least some
proof
but here it's a very interesting
situation because apparently berlin
doesn't like facts
and i have a different
material
we have noted another statement by the
foreign ministry of germany
and such a statement was also made by
as can be
seen
from
the previous
my previous remarks they do it in
coordination
with them
the u.s
they have responded to the information
that was published about the funding of
navalny's projects via employees
that were hired by german and united
states diplomatic missions and moscow in
moscow
we have noted the activities of
german and american diplomatic missions
in moscow the german side has not been
shy
to accuse russian official agencies to
allegedly
attempt to construct charges of direct
financing of the blogger
we are not constructing anything we are
only pointing out the facts that have
been revealed
and they are as follows
and we do this answering the questions
by
the media and the facts are as follows
foreign embassies in moscow hired
russian citizens
each embassy has its own practice they
paid them money as remuneration it's not
up to us it's up to them
which they in turn transferred to
relevant structures
these are just facts and we have
confirmed them
that's an interesting situation when we
are accused they do not give us anything
aside from these accusations and
delegations
then they try to come up with a
punishment and try to
implement it but when we point out any
facts and we are not accusing anyone of
anything these are just facts
they plunge into hysteria it's different
they say
america does not only state that these
categoric data
is totally false
they accuse us of attempts to intimidate
citizens for supporting the political
opposition it's ridiculous
dear
dls colleagues
perhaps you should
come up with a certain material to
consult when you speak
so that you do not contradict yourself
because it's bizarre to hear such
statements
from the overseas beacons of democracy
who in the best traditions of the
which hunter the whole cold war actually
in january this year
they actually launched a veritable
prosecution of their own opposition in
the united states
you do remember the
that people were
dismissed from jobs they were put to
prison
throughout many years american media
american official structures
have been showing various
structures and were linking
compatriots and post-soviet uh
origin people
they have been analyzing them in depth
they have been talking about who they
vote for who they support the published
photos names
an endless chain
of groundless accusations we have done
nothing of the kind we have simply
confirmed a fact
an interesting situation isn't it
and i would like to
reiterate why
are we drawing attention to this fact
simply because our diplomats were
expelled from a number of countries
under the false pretext of interfering
with the electoral processes or
supporting on an opposition movement and
by the way today we're going to speak
about a similar story
about an article that was published in
the western press
and our diplomats that were
accused of interference have never been
shown any facts no facts whatsoever
otherwise it would have been known
and this is exactly why
we are speaking to our western partners
why is that so
why are there such double standards
in this regard we have received
questions
from journalists from the dost media let
me read each question let me give you
the answers
in these materials did you mean the
publications
of the relevant website of the committee
of the defense of national something
like that i guess
when we published these materials we
were responding to the questions of the
media
the journalists asked us to confirm
whether or not russian citizens
sponsoring relevant structures worked in
foreign diplomatic missions
we don't believe it possible to speak
about personal about some names because
it's about personal data and the next
question is
how exactly you checked the list so you
know this is a very weird question
the next question
do we get it right that russians in
foreign embassies
as it says
locally employed personnel
work through
one of the mfa structures using its pr
channels
you know regarding the us embassy they
are employing
staff not through mfa staff not using
mfa russian mfa channels they haven't
been done it since 1980s it is an open
source information distinguished
journalist from the dost channel
and you can take a look at them
regarding other countries
diplomatic stuff then it can be
different on a case by case case-by-case
basis and you have to address embassies
themselves the next question we found
out that the list has names of people
who have never worked in foreign
embassies
but received scholarships to study
languages and
for the trade
for working to um translate books so i
would like to ask you how exactly you
checked this list
i have already answered your question
and i would like to highlight that we do
not
discuss personal data
and the next question you call the
situation a scheme
i guess that's
that's it
and here's the question
why do you think that this scheme
why are you using this word scheme
that's the question so i'm using this
word in accordance with the dictionary
dictionary by ushakov
it says that's him
is a general picture of something a
picture of a report a picture of a novel
etc etc that's the sense in which i use
the word scheme
our article was written
so i would like to say that
it's up to the journalists and activists
who we may find out the truth and please
pay attention to it
and one more question from a dost tv
channel you compare the situation with a
response by western countries
but this time we're not talking about
western diplomats we're talking about
russian diplomats
and teachers
don't you think that it's in
inadequate to compare diplomat and the
teacher
you're correct
but we must compare the source of income
and the source is the same that was
income was pre provided by the
government of a foreign country a
foreign country that pays
a locally
employed
citizen if you have more questions if
you have more questions please address
us
the next topic is the situation in
beginning
as you know
on the
5th of september a group of military
officers led by former special
operations battalion commander colonel
mamadee doombuy carried out an armed
seizure of power arrested president alfa
conde dissolved the government and
abrogated the constitution moscow
expresses alarm and concern about the
violent change of power in guinea and we
demand the release of alpha khande his
immunity must also be respected we deem
it extremely important to prevent any
escalation of tensions
and to take necessary steps to make the
situation constitutional once again
we believe that there is no alternative
but to restore law and in order as soon
as possible and to establish a national
dialogue according to information from
the russian embassy in conakry the
situation in guinea is generally calm
state institutions continue to work
normally and the transition of power is
being conducted locally
a national committee for unification and
development has been instituted whose
task is to ensure a peaceful transition
of power on the 6th of september the
leaders of the military coup met in
concrete with former members of the
government and leaders of state
structures
during the meeting mamadi dumboya stated
that a government of national unity
would be established shortly
he also assured that foreign mining
companies would be able to continue
operations unhindered with guinea's
maritime borders opened for the export
of mining products
on the same day it was announced that
the air borders would reopen and
commercial and humanitarian flights
would resume
according to our diplomatic mission in
conacry the situation around the russian
embassy in guinea remains calm
there were no incidents involving
russian citizens or russian companies
staff working in the country
constant communication is being
maintained with our compatriots and all
necessary measures are being taken to
ensure their safety and security
we still urge russian citizens to
refrain from traveling to the republic
of guinea until the situation has fully
normalized
the next topic is
the following on september 12th the
russian embassy in the united states and
the new york city ngo shiller institute
are planning to hold a ceremony to pay
tribute to the victims of the 9 11
terrorist attack
the ceremony will take place at the
monumental composition the struggle
against world terrorism which is also
called tear of grief located in beyond
new jersey in the opposite side of the
hudson river from manhattan
this sculpture
was inaugurated on september 11th 2006
it was created by zurob tsaritel a
president of the russian academy of arts
and presented to the american people as
a gift from the russian federation
the commemoration ceremony will hear a
solemn greeting from zurab teritelli
a speech will be delivered by
sergey of sanikov russian consul general
in new york and brief remarks will be
made by officials from the police and
fire departments as well as relatives of
the victims the ceremony will also see a
rendition of russian and u.s anthems
by the schiller institute chorus
now a few words on
the anniversary of the arctic council
the beginning of russia's second
chairmanship in the arctic council this
year coincided with the organization's
25th anniversary the history of the
arctic council can in many ways be
considered a success story
the council originated in the early
1990s in the finnish city called
rovaniemi on the basis of regional
environmental cooperation was formally
established in 1996 in ottawa
since then it has become an influential
forum for intergovernmental dialogue
among the arctic states sustainable
development of the polar regions
importantly for over 25 years the arctic
council's six permanent participants the
organizations that represent the
interests of the indigenous peoples of
the north have been an integral part of
this dialogue the anniversary
celebrations include a number of
initiatives and projects from a
documentary film
about the history and accomplishments of
the council two roundtable discussions
and workshops about the future of the
arctic region held in the member and
observer states of the council
information events are also planned to
be held on the social media channels of
the council and its members more
information
is available on the arctic council's
official website
i think
this organization is a crucial example
of cooperating of cooperation between
states and ngos
and the format of an international
structure
and other
similar organizations were talking about
human rights council
the 48th session of the united human
rights council will be held in geneva
from september 13th to october 8th it is
expected to discuss a wide range of
topical issues in the promotion and
protection of human rights including
countering racism and contemporary forms
of slavery the indigenous people
situation the human rights dimension of
private secured and military companies
forced disappearances and illegal
detention mercenaries the right to water
and sanitation respect of senior persons
rights
one of the central topics of the
upcoming session will be the negative
impact of unilateral coercive measures
on human rights which will be the
subject of a separate discussion
there will also be a dialogue with the
special rapporteur of the human rights
council who will present a detailed
analysis of the concept types and
interpretation of such unlawful
sanctions with a focus on their extra
territorial consequences
as is traditional a number of
country-specific topics will be
addressed including the human rights
situation in yemen libya myanmar syria
and ukraine
during the forthcoming session of the
human rights council the russian
delegation will continue to consistently
pursue a policy of developing a
constructive and mutually respectful
dialogue overcoming confrontation and
promoting a unifying agenda on urgent
human rights
issues
i would like to separately dwell on one
topic that we have already commented on
but it deserves separate attention we
are talking about the publication
by the new york times
i don't really know
what's the topic of this publication we
can say it's about the situation in
catalonia
on the other hand we can say that it's
about how
once again
the media
that has a long tradition and a long
history has become a hostage of its lack
of professionalism
or has become a hostage of lobbying
centers of politicians
i don't know
so a few days ago
we would like to draw your attention to
our rebuttal of the new york times piece
called merit
kremlin spies a shadowy mission to
moscow and unrest in catalonia published
two days ago on the foreign ministry
website
in the published materials that contain
false information about russia's section
it looks more like a james bond story
or just a bad novel
pulp fiction
we can't even say that it was an article
because it's a cheap fake and it's not
worthy being called an article
let me remind you that we are talking
about an alleged sensation about the
connections of catalan officials with
russia
i would like to find out how reliable
the sources of the new york times relied
on are especially
when the catalans themselves
reviewed the fabrications presented in
the material the authors refer to some
secret european intelligence report
which contains obvious misinformation
you know we can come up with uh secret
intelligence reports of any sort
uh secret intelligence report on mars
on ocean
et cetera et cetera but
anyway it tells about some meetings of
joseph luis ally senior advisor to the
former head of the catalonian government
carlos
putch them on with oleg cyril molotov
russian deputy foreign minister which
never was the case
because neither in russia nor
in moscow
nor somewhere else in the world it has
not been the case
learned about joseph lewis ally
by reading this article and he was
outraged
by this fake and i understand him very
much and it also says that uh mr alley
also met with the head of rosa
rudinich's to yevgeny primakov
i would like to draw your attention to
the fact that mr primakov himself has
already commented on
this information in the telegram channel
in case
you haven't seen it i'll tell you evgeny
primakov did cross paths with mr ally
once
when he worked as journalist
he wasn't
covering the fact that he was uh the
head of the ross at rudenshire store the
fact was he wasn't
uh occupying this post he has been
appointed later
their pathcrost crossed when mr primakov
was journalist
he was also an author and host of the
program which is called international
review
so
in this capacity mr primakov wanted to
interview carlos pujdemon
at the same time i would like to
highlight evgeny primakov had nothing to
do with ross at rudinshisto at the time
it was before he was appointed to the
post in june 2019
so the interview with carlos pujdemon
was indeed recorded in brussels but
without primakov it was shown almost a
month later after the spanish elections
so
even this fact contradicts the
allegations that he in some way
influenced the situation catalonia
it was shown a month later in a
truncated form without broadcasting
political slogans in order to avoid any
accusations of attempts to interfere in
spanish spain's internal affairs
unfortunately this is not the first time
that some spanish media have again and
again propagated the provocative
narrative of alleged russian
interference and spain's internal
affairs in connection with the catalan
events that took place in recent years
the authors of such publications are not
particularly imaginative the overused
speculations about the russian trace and
the separatist processes in catalonia i
get in more and more fantasmagoric
details
but once again it looks more like
tabloids pie detective stories
i'd like to remind you that the russian
foreign ministry has repeatedly stated
its principled and unambiguous position
that the situation in catalonia is
exclusively an internal matter of spain
and that developments around the catalan
issue should take place strictly in
accordance with spanish legislation
we have published these statements on
our website we have also said many times
that the basis of our relations with
spain was the unconditional respect for
sovereignty and territorial integrity of
the country and is well known to our
spanish partners
as to the new york times fake story we
promptly responded to it
and published accurate information
refuting that nonsense
but the difficulty is that you cannot
rebut nonsense
they publish materials that cannot be
reputed
you can rebut
something
uh that has been that presented in a not
in an unaccurate manner but you cannot
refute nonsense
apparently this
is what
two journalists who wrote this article
called professionalism we're talking
about michael schwartz and jose bautista
and their names
were inscribed in gold in the world
history of fakes speaking of the new
york times traditions
i invite you to look at kazimo classics
reprint of an old work published last
year a research called a test of the
news
originally published as a supplement to
the new republic in
this work by journalists walter lipman
and charles mertz
focuses on the new york times coverage
of the october revolution in russia
the independent authors found many
inaccuracies and distortions in the
reporting
they explicitly state to the reader
we will provide the link in the text of
the briefing so they explicitly state to
the reader the news about russia is a
case of seeing not what was but what men
wished to see
thus according to lipman and mert's
calculations between late 1970 and
1917 and late 1919 the new york times
reported 91 times that the soviet
government had fallen or was about to
fall
as can be seen the new york times
journalists were wrong in their
forecasts exactly 91 times
what an enviable consistency
however there are
journalistic standards
and it's time to change and i would like
to draw your attention that we
are waiting
for the retraction of this information
and we will closely monitor the
situation
the next subject is also about the
united kingdom we've taken note that in
early september the united kingdom
introduced stricter rules for the
operation of online platforms including
the largest social networks the document
entitled age appropriate design code and
is presented by the authorities as aimed
at preventing and combating various
undesirable patterns of interaction
between network operators and underage
users
in particular it is now forbidden to
track the location of children to use
targeted advertising
and other
personalized content
and to impose a prolonged stay on the
internet
despite the rather
innocent
title of code from the point of view of
the supposed legal consequences in this
case violators face fines of up to four
percent of the company's turnover
and when we are talking about internet
giants
we are talking about colossal sums of
money
at first glance
this is
a good initiative
however it has launched another wave of
discussions in the british government
mainly in the power block on the
advisability of further tightening
requirements for i.t companies of course
solely out of concern for the protection
of children's welfare among the ideas
voiced are the need for a ban on
end-to-end data encryption ensuring
access to it by the intelligence
services and confirm an identity when
registering and using social networks
it is curious that the same set of
proposals
has recently been accompanied by a
slightly different set of arguments
mainly related to the needs of migration
control and the fight against terrorism
in this context we believe that the main
thing is not that the innovations in
british law per se
they are just generally in line with the
worldwide trend
do you desire of states to define the
limits of what is permitted for internet
giants
suffice it to recall the recent
legislative innovations in australia
germany france china and the united
states including at the level of
individual u.s states more and more
often we hear news of fines being issued
to such operators for example in the
case of the record 225 million euros
from the relevant irish regulator
who ordered facebook to pay for failing
to inform users about the collection and
use of their personal data
it is noteworthy that the same british
officials and the non-governmental
structures guided by them deny this
right to other
others
we do remember the hysteria by
government structures ngos journalists
forums
when our british partners
started this hysteria around legislation
that was developed in the russian
federation
i do believe currently that the british
are using the same ideas in their own
national law
it's time to decide whether they dislike
such ideas and principles in general and
they consider them
impossible to use or
they consider them normal in the latter
case it's time for them to stop
criticizing our country
they should be consistent in their
actions because
you should not think that you are the
only one
who is dignified and worthy
in the world
when it comes to other they attribute
any steps towards streamlining and
civilizing a country's relations with
internet monopolists to an attack on
free speech
once again it's about double standards
and oh no this is different
london has done that a lot
seems
that in the current situation of almost
complete
uncontrollability and unaccountability
of online platforms in the global i.t
sphere
we can find solutions to this problem
either
by introducing national and regional
regimes to regulate their activities and
in this case we need to remind our
western partners that each state has the
right to do this
or
by developing uniform approaches
to the codification of this fear
universally recognized by all interested
parties
we would prefer to take the second path
we have repeatedly called to do this and
we would like to remind you of our
legislators initiative the council of
the federation had published
this proposal and had distributed it in
international platforms
and we should draw the attention of our
british colleagues to the
inconsistencies in their approach
for the time being
we call on them to refrain from
qualifying these measures as
inappropriate while they themselves do
the same
on the 6th of september a new secondary
school was opened
in sinwal
instead of the building that was
destroyed in august 20 2008 during the
georgian aggression
the facility was built with the
financial assistance
of the russian federation
the ceremony was attended by the
leadership of south satya added by the
president the russian ambassador to
south syria former graduates of the
school who are now politicians
representatives of the diplomatic corps
public and mass media in his speech the
head of the of south syria expressed
gratitude to the russian federation for
the large-scale aid rendered to the
republic including that directed to the
modernization of the social
infrastructure
our country will continue to provide
comprehensive assistance to this
brotherly republic and its economic
development
on the 7th of september on the 7th of
september
in dushanbe du
a ceremony was held to
mark the donation of 10 russian-made
ambulance vehicles to tajikistan by
russia
the event was attended by russian
ambassador deputy head of the
directorate to the president of the
russian federation deputy prime minister
of tajikistan and other officials this
is not the first time russia has
provided assistance to tajikistan to
strengthen its national health care
system
our
ambassador has spoken a lot about that
such
cases are covered
our cooperation in this area is
developing dynamically including
the joint fight against the coronavirus
infection
currently 2
700 tajik students are
studying medicine in russia
this is also a major contribution to the
development of tajikistan's health care
on russia's part the donation of
vehicles carrying state-of-the-art
medical equipment including portable
ventilator machines defibrillator
monitors electric cardiographs
oxygen inhalers and much more
is proof
that russia
values
our bilateral and strategically
important relationship
it is emblematic that this event took
place on the eve of significant
international events
that are scheduled in tajikistan
russia is one of tajikistan's key
partners in strengthening its healthcare
system and epidemiological well-being
over the past few years with russia's
financial support tajikistan has
received four mobile clinics on the
basis of kama's truck
specializing in primary care and
diagnostics of hiv viral hepatitis and
other infectious diseases a mobile rapid
diagnostics laboratory based on gas
truck two medical trains that can
provide integrated treatment and
preventive care in remote areas of the
country
as part of our joint fight against
coronavirus russia has donated to
tajikistan test kits and relevant
reagents as well as fifty thousand doses
of sputnik the vaccine
since the beginning of the pandemic ross
petreb nazor has sent six expert
delegations to the republic to provide
practical assistance in combating this
infectious disease
moreover with russian support the who is
implementing projects in tajikistan to
reduce maternal infant and child
mortality
and to identify risks associated with
non-communicable diseases
a few more topics on the 5th of
september
in sao saotame and principi
the second round of presidential
elections took place according to the
data made public by the national
electoral commission the
candidate of the independent democratic
action party carlos manuel villanova
received the highest number of votes
57.54
observers from the economic community of
central african states noted that the
voting took place in a peaceful and calm
atmosphere moscow has welcomed the
successful holding of the presidential
elections in the country and hopes that
the country's society
will continue its staggering steady
progress towards stable social and
economic development
and
before this briefing we have received a
request
by from a number of information agencies
that asked us to get back
to the situation around bbc sarah
rainsford
we have received
quotes
from her interview to
the russian medium
where she
has
said something strange something that is
not true and despite numerous and
exhaustive explanations regarding the
reasons
that her
license was revoked
as a response measure
to london's
persecution against russian media
outlets bordering on
outright humiliation madam rainsford
continues to make public remarks that
make us doubt not only her professional
integrity but basic human decency as
well
and her attitude to journalism and
journalists in general in her recent
interview and i reiterate we actually
did receive requests from mass media
that asked us to
the fact that they as russian
journalists feel simply
humiliated
by sarah rainsford
in connection to her remarks including
in the context of
separate russian media outlets in her
recent interview
she combined her emotional stories and
tear-provoking stories about her
upcoming
leave in russia and her speculations and
links to uncold sources of course our
bbc sources where can she get any
sources about herself
this is all peppered up with blatant
lies and she continues to predate that
she does not understand the origin of
the problem but she also considers
herself to be the victim of an
oppression of free speech in russia
and at the same time strangely
she
speaks against her russian colleagues
russian journalists
i believe that madam sarah rainsford
should begin considering
the fact that she is
insulting russian journalists i'm not
speaking about russian authorities even
she states things that are not true and
she questions the work of her colleagues
and what's curious
she comments
on
russian media outlets and russian
journalists and as we
were told by the journalists madame
rainford did not ask for any
clarifications for from them
we would like to refute her lies
the fact that she is leaving russia is a
direct consequence of many years
systemic and
unfounded refusal by british authorities
to contin to discontinue the practice of
discriminating against russian
journalists
london is practicing
manipulations
and refusal of visas against russian
journalists it is well known to the bbc
tv channel because we have drawn their
attention to this problem
on
multiple occasions we have also drawn
the attention of the official london to
the fact that we will be forced to
reciprocate
maybe we are not going to mirror these
measures we are not going to act against
british journalists the way they acted
against russian journalists because that
was bordering on insults and humiliation
sarah rainsford as a bbc reporter is
lying when she says that russian
journalists and british soil are linked
with something else aside from london's
lack of desire to see tasks reported to
reporters in the uk
if it's true let her give us proof
she is lying about the fact that such
incidents are not isolated isolated
and when tots attempted to send new
journalists it was unsuccessful bbc is
aware of the fact as is sarah rainsford
and i would like to point out that a
number of tasks journalists
simply failed to
submit their documents these documents
were not accepted
she is unwrittenly or writtenly
lying when she is
hinting
that russian reporters
are not up to the standards of
checking
according to british standards i wonder
what these standards
might be
if journalists cannot obtain visas
as to the fact that the british do not
give visas to russian diplomats
that receive british invitations to
participate in
free speech forums
we have already mentioned that
the british does not let accredited
russian journalists to advance link to
the freedom of speech and protection of
journalists we have already spoken about
that as well this is something new
entirely new standards to obtain visas
what can i say
madam sarah rainford
not only comments on affairs that her
russian colleagues are facing in britain
without any objectivity
she also opposes herself to them
she's trying to
tell that she's better than them without
giving us any facts
that's something you entirely
some kind of unknown british humor
perhaps
pray excuse me but let me quote her
she is a right journalist because she is
public because she is given air time but
as for russian journalists we are
speaking about some
anonymous journalists supported by the
government
i wonder why i wonder what makes sarah
rainsford think
that they are anonymous that's another
lie of hers
bbc and britain in general knows their
names and
they are rather famous they are well
known to the russian public
and now as for
state support
here i would like to explain something
and
respond to this comment made by madame
rainsford
the independent and
public sarah has received endorsement
by the state minister on america from
the foreign
office and the foreign secretary mr raab
they have both asked for her
what would be her response to that i
wonder
if she believes
that governmental support
is the difference between a good and a
bad journalist well
what kind of a journalist is chanel
a valid question isn't it let her answer
that if she's so public as she claims
when she questions our readiness to
reconsider her case given reciprocal
stabs by the uk
sarah rainsford shows disrespect to
russian journalists
and to the gesture of goodwill on our
part
when we decided not to continue this
downward spiral
of mutual revenge
but to give london an opportunity to
save its face
to give
visa
to the russian reporter and in that case
we are ready to give the
visa to sarah rainsford bbc reporter
here i would like to point out once
again
the way to settle
this situation
the fault for which lies exclusively
with the british
is despite these
deceitful statements by the british
reporter
here i reiterate
as soon as the russian reporter receives
the visa sarah rainsford would be free
to
address the russian consulate
no need for fantasies anymore
each fantasies
of british reporters will be rebutted by
our facts it might sound rough but it
wasn't us who started this and now i'm
ready to answer your questions let us
take a look
who is present who has registered
uh do we have russia today here with us
daniel hawking um
last week
press release by the executive body bbc
again
have some pity on me
[Music]
we are spending too much time on them
all right i'm ready i'll be happy to
answer your question
it is about
the agenda
the complaint was about the
program
that was aired in november
last year on bbc
in that tv program bb
c hinted that the former inspector of
opcw
dubbed as alex
was motivated to speak about his doubts
by a financial
reward from wikileaks amounting to one
hundred thousand dollars moreover he was
convinced that this attack was
staged and he only cooperated with the
journalists that supported moscow and
damascus during this investigation bbc
had
accepted the fact that it was not true
and this misrepresentation of the in
fact of the inspector was not in line
with the quality of such programs it was
published in their website here is my
question the fact
that bbc misrepresented the ideas of the
former inspector
and 10 months later
had accepted
the
substandard quality of this program what
does it speak about the narrative of
syria
and
britain's attitude to dissent
in back in november last year we took
note of the bbc radio 4 program
published by
bbc
and prepared by
journalist
claude
the program was devoted to the high
profile episode
with the alleged use of chemical weapons
on april the 7th 2018
this topic this
broadcast was not different from many
other
western mainstream
programs and it had as a goal to use all
and any methods including unacceptable
ones to distract the international
community from the missile attack
by
britain and
france and the u.s
in syria for an alleged chemical attacks
by syrian governmental troops
duma case remains a vivid example of how
the armed syrian opposition
and its affiliated pseudo-humanitarian
ngo
real gangsters the white helmets with
the patronage of western intelligence
agencies have initiated endless
provocations using toxic substances to
demonize the legitimately elected syrian
government
the white helmets as well as
is a british corporation that has been
supported by the british government
so the leadership of the technical
secretariat of the specialized
organization for the prohibition of
chemical weapons has also contributed to
distorting the relayed reality this is
evidenced by the falsification of the
final report of the opcw on the results
of the investigation of this chemical
provocation for which damascus was
initially blamed despite the original
version of the document prepared by
former employee
of the opcw on the basis of objective
data
by the way ex-employees of the opcw that
drafted the original version of the
document
they deserve respect and a special
attention by the media because they were
not afraid to later
publicly declare that the aforementioned
report was falsified
to the political order of the aggressor
countries
that were really behind this strike
not surprisingly peter hitchens who can
hardly be suspect suspected of having
pro-russian or even pro-syrian views
closely followed the official position
on the accusations of the syrian
leadership's allergic use of chemical
weapons and asked very uncomfortable
questions to his own government while
drawing the appropriate conclusions they
were often at odds with the picture that
authorities in britain and other western
countries were trying to present
thus the indignation of peter hitchens
is quite understandable he was denied
the right to have his own opinion on the
situation and duma
by an unscrupulous journalist
this journalist also said that the
motives of one of the two former apple
employees of the opcw technical
secretariat known under the pseudonym
alex were selfish this former employee
was just trying to protect the
scientific reliability of the first
version of the report on chemical
provocation and human and he was accused
of being bribed
to protect his position
to defend his position and
he was denied the right to his
professional reputation and human
dignity
so the positive outcome of peter
hitchens appeal before a special unit of
the bbc media corporation inspires some
optimism on the one hand
however i don't think that it i do not
expect any serious progress
it's one thing when it is a low bro
liable of a highly respected journalist
and scholar with an excellent reputation
that can easily be disproved in court
it's another thing when a state in this
case the united kingdom is not
interested in an objective investigation
of what happened in duma and continues
to distort events through its controlled
media in an effort to evade
responsibility along with its nato
allies for the aggression undertaken in
violation of the u.n charter and
generally recognized norms of
international law
we already we have already discussed and
commented on the falsification campaign
that pops up now and then
and manifests itself
for example i have commented on the new
york times piece
i've commented on other examples for
example russian hackers etc etc
every day we come up with relevant
examples
and one more thing
the count on the fact that even
if the slice broadcast is on tv even if
it's
retracted
then
nevertheless
it will take some time and an image a
distorted image will be
fixed in the target audience's minds
and secondly
few people will see these retractions
rebuttals
etc
and it is not being discussed publicly
this rebuttals and refutals because we
called on cnn on numerous occasions
that showed
a fake peace and trying to
we ask them to
reflect another point of view it has
been done but not in the format we
desired and after a long period of time
and it was irrelevant at that moment
if you're satisfied with the answer then
we will move on the international life
are you with us
madame zakarova
i have a question
other plans to hold meetings with the
new leadership of afghanistan in the
near future and at what level could they
take place
answer
i would like to start with the fact that
at this stage working contacts are being
maintained with representatives of the
taliban movement through the russian
embassy in kabul
there are no plans to hold other
contacts or negotiations with the new
afghan government
our embassy in kabul
on a regular basis comments on the
situation in afghanistan
do we have news rule with us
madam zakharova good afternoon thank you
for the opportunity to ask a question
my question is
could you please introduce yourself
sona rustamova
news portal news rule
question it has recently been exactly
300 days
since the trilateral statement of the
leaders of russia azerbaijan and armenia
entered into force
how do you currently
and the
the parties to the agreement
accuse themselves of violating this
statement
how do the russian mfa currently how
does the russian mfa currently assess
the implementation of the agreement's
provision
answer why did you decide to take note
of the 300 days thing
but it's it's it's about the
uh anniversary but have you celebrated
200 days since the signature of this
statement
no
so my question is whether you will ask
me question every 100 days
because i'm really interested why did
you point it out why did you point out
that it has been exactly 300 days since
the signature of the statement
you haven't celebrated the 200 days
anniversary but you celebrate the 300
300 days anniversary
you don't know but i know
your question is related to the report
recently posted on social networks by
the azerbaijani foreign ministry about
achievements in 300 days since the
signing of the trilateral statement
dated november 9th 2020.
for our part we regularly report on the
activities of the russian peacekeeping
contingent which is reliably enforcing
the ceasefire along the line of contact
and the latching corridor no significant
violations have been recorded in the
zone of responsibility of the russian
peacekeepers this is confirmed both in
baku and in yerevan we share our
assessments of the situation on the
azerbaijani armenian border where armed
incidents have occurred in recent months
we inform about the work on unblocking
of economic and transport ties in the
region which is carried out within the
trilateral working group co-chaired by
the deputy prime ministers of russia
azerbaijan and armenia
in general we informed the public about
all the mediation efforts aimed at
improving baku yerevan relations
which we
undertaken both bilaterally and
trilaterally as well as within
multilateral formats
i think that
we better take stock
uh note after some round anniversaries
but we will
provide
a large
material to the one year anniversary of
the statement
do you have other questions
no i have none
do we have moscow buckle with us
yes good afternoon madam zakarova
official yerivan has recently begun
actively linking the issue of signing a
peace agreement with azerbaijan to the
determination of karabakh's status
as far as we remember
both russian president vladimir putin
and russian foreign minister sergey
lavrov have repeatedly stressed that the
status issue is rather an issue for the
future
and it's not worth stirring things up
now
how can official moscow comment on the
statement or condition from yerevan
answer
we are closely following the discussions
in azerbaijan and armenia on signing a
peace treaty between these countries and
the resolution of the nagorno-karabakh
status issue
unfortunately the fundamental
disagreements between the parties on
political issues remain that is why this
stage we consider as priority the strict
implementation of all provisions of the
trilateral high-level agreements dated
november 9th 2020 and january 11 2021
above all this concerns maintenance of
the ceasefire regime the resolution of
humanitarian issues and the unblocking
of economic and transport links in the
region
we expect that these steps will help to
create conditions for the normalization
of azerbaijani armenian relations and
for reaching a final political
settlement
if you have no more questions we move on
do we have
the compatriot magazine called together
from slovakia with us yes madame
zakarova
i have a question regarding the
beginning of the new academic year
i would like to know
whether russia provides great uh support
to young compatriots live in abroad and
foreign youth and get an education
russian universities
what kind of support do they receive
what means scholarships visa support
some kind of benefits for accommodation
or transportation medical care russian
language courses
or other means of support or benefits
are there certain trends
of increasing the number of foreign
students in russian media amid the
pandemic
answer
indeed in recent years
foreigners and compatriots have become
more interested
in getting higher education in russia
some statistics
in
there were there were 150 000 people
studying both on the budget and
commercial basis and in
there are about 300 000 of
in them with the russian federation
government decree dated december 18 2020
number 2150 the quota for education and
russian educational institutions for
foreign citizens and
stateless persons
including compatriots living abroad
at the expense of budgetary allocations
from the federal budget in the academic
year
2021-2022 increased to
eighteen thousand places
when in previous years the number was
fifteen thousand
students that fall under this category
study in russian universities free of
charge
moreover the academic year
2022-2023 provides a quota of 23 000
places and 30 000 places for post 2023
academic years
for the period of study foreign students
are provided with places and dormitories
they are paid monthly scholarships and
for students arriving from far abroad
there is an opportunity to take
preparatory courses in russian language
and i think that every university has
its website
it has its own conditions and prospects
for studying for
foreign students
so every single university provides
additional information in this regard do
we have other questions today
it seems not to be the case
since we have no more question today
questions today then i would like
to say goodbye all the best to you stay
healthy bye
thank you very much
you